Today, we're going to show you
how to build a DIY teleprompter
that will let you
read out a script
while you're looking
right at the camera.
[Music]
Guys, believe it or not,
almost everything
that we've said on this channel
has been without the use
of a teleprompter.
Some of you may be
surprised to learn that,
because in my first videos,
I was awkwardly staring straight
at the camera, rarely blinking,
or interacting
with my surroundings.
It was a struggle for a while.
I'd like to think
I've gotten better,
and don't need
to do that anymore.
However, we are going to show
you how to build a teleprompter,
because they can be very useful.
Here's the basic idea.
Using foam core, hot glue,
and a sheet of acrylic,
we can help you make
a teleprompter that will fit
to your camera and smartphone.
So guys, a lot of YouTubers
and a lot of people
on TV use teleprompters.
They're incredibly useful.
They make it really easy.
If you have a lot
of bullet points,
you've got to hit really fast.
Well, you've got
to memorize that,
unless you have a teleprompter.
Teleprompters aren't
for every situation.
If you're acting
on stage, or screen,
something like that,
then you can't be looking
right at the camera,
which is where the cues are
usually going to be scrolling.
But for anything
where you're really trying
to just focus on the camera
itself, maybe vlogging,
or showing a DIY video
that has a lot to say,
it can really save a lot of time
so you don't have to sit
and memorize lines forever.
The supplies you'll need
to build this are
actually very simple.
We've got a sheet of acrylic.
This is an 8x10 sheet I picked
up at the hardware store
for like less than four bucks.
We've got a sheet of craft foam.
This stuff comes
from Hobby Lobby,
costs about $1.50.
This is the thickest
stuff they have.
You could get something
a little bit thinner,
but I like it with
the thicker version.
We have a hot glue gun,
pretty much any hot glue gun
is going to work.
And then we also have foam core.
This is the stuff
that's paper on the outside,
and like a styrofoam middle.
We've got a
clicking razor blade,
very useful because
if it started get to dull,
you can just break the tip off,
and keep using the rest of it.
Pencil, it's good
for marking things,
and this piece of paper,
which were actually
just going to fold,
and use as a 45
degree angle guide.
The other things you're going to
need are a camera to film with,
and a smartphone to run
the teleprompter app.
This app that I'm using is
the Parrot Teleprompter app.
The Parrot Teleprompter
is a commercially
available version of
what we're building today.
It's a bit more sturdy than what
we are going to build today,
but it cost quite
a bit more as well.
The app however is free,
so that's what we're going to
be using with our DIY version.
Before we started this build,
I reached out to a friend
of mine named Brigham,
who actually invented
the Parrot Teleprompter,
and I asked him some questions
about his design
and invention process
so we could know what
we were getting into.
So the design itself is
actually deceptively simple,
but there are
some few basic things
that you really
want to keep in mind
when you're building
one of these to make
it actually flawless.
One of those things is the angle
of your acrylic to make sure
that everything is actually
lining up correctly.
The other thing
that you really need to take
into account is the vignette.
You don't want your camera lens
to catch the side of the box
of the teleprompter itself.
We're going to want to build
this custom to our camera
and our phone.
Every phone is going
to be different,
a lot of cameras
are going to be different.
You can see,
this right here is the camera
that our cameraman
Mark usually uses.
He's currently using
our emergency backup camera,
so we can see
his primary camera.
Sorry, Mark.
And so we have
to build onto this,
so that it all works smoothly.
So to start off,
we're just going to cut some 4
inch strips of our foam core
that's a large enough size
that we can cut it
down to what we need,
but we won't end up with
any pieces that are too small.
The first piece that we're going
to want to cut out of these,
that's actually going to be part
of the body of the teleprompter
is going to be the pieces
that hold our phone.
This is going to be
the basic idea here
is we're just going
to have a slit,
a rectangular hole cut into this
that our phone fits in nicely,
and that's going
to hold it in place,
and just generally do
everything we want to in terms
of keeping our hardware
where we need it.
[Music]
I measured correctly.
That's actually quite snug.
As you can see,
it's not falling out like that.
That's pretty good thing,
and then trim this,
I'm going to give myself
too much space here.
It's not going to be this tall.
This is just moving on,
and now, we need to build
another one exactly like that.
Got our two pieces
that hold the phone, however,
with my particular phone,
I have the camera
that sticks out.
It's not quite flush
with the rest of the phone body,
and I want it to fit
just right so I'm actually going
to cut that notch out as well.
I'm gonna show you why.
So you can see
here the width that
the teleprompter text runs at,
and we want to encase
it about that width,
and so we want this side to get
in a little bit closer.
But right now,
it's bumping into my camera.
So I need to cut a notch
so it doesn't do that.
[Music]
How did I do?
Nice.
[Music]
So obviously, we're going
to cut these down to size.
But the next step
is going to be to cut
some 45 degree angle slits
into the side,
that's going to be what holds
our acrylic piece in place.
Piece of paper folded
across diagonally.
It should give us
a perfect 45 degree angle.
Here is where we're going
to want our piece of acrylic.
We've got the piece of paper,
and I'm just going
to set that right
onto the screen of the phone,
and then this line,
where we can mark.
Same thing on the other side.
We've got our 45 degree
angle lines, and now,
we need to cut out a small slot,
the same thickness
as our acrylic sheet.
We have the lines drawn longer
than they needed to be.
We don't need to have
this extend all the way down
off of the foam core.
We're going to have
it stopped right here,
a little bit above
the height of the phone.
We can see that it's
maybe five millimeters
above the height
of the phone screen,
and on the other end,
it doesn't need to extend
all the way to the end
of the phone screen either.
So we're just going to cut
it off right about here,
and all the light
from the phone will be shining
up this direction.
This is actually an interesting
demonstration right here
about how exactly
a teleprompter works.
So our camera will be
filming this direction.
So we'll have the lens
of the camera will be
about right here,
filming out here.
This is where the person
being filmed is.
Phone screen is down
here pointing up.
The acrylic is reflective,
but not as much as a mirror.
So light coming
off of our phone,
the text that's
being written on it,
is going to bounce up.
Some of it is going to go right
through the acrylic,
and it's just going to keep
going that direction.
But some of the light is going
to hit the acrylic pane,
and at a 45 degree angle,
it's going to bounce off.
And remember, this is
where we are over here.
So we're going to be able to see
what's on the phone screen
as it bounces off this way.
But because of the angle,
the camera isn't going
to see any of that light.
The phone isn't going
to bounce light
off the acrylic this direction.
That just doesn't happen.
It's only going to go either
straight through the acrylic,
or bounce off the 45 degree
angle out towards us.
So a tip for you,
if you're ever cutting
mat for something
that needs to look really
really pretty, make sure
that you're cutting inwards.
You don't want to ever cut
outwards towards the mat
you're going to be keeping.
You might end up
with like a score mark
that you don't want.
In this case,
it doesn't really matter,
but for future reference.
So you cut towards the piece
that isn't going to matter.
So now, to know what size
of acrylic we need,
we're going to measure
the cuts we've already made.
Now, what we also have
to take into account is
how far apart we want these,
and again, that depends
on the phone you're using.
So we'll start by just cutting
a 4 inch wide strip of acrylic,
kind of like we did
with our pieces of foam core,
and we'll then chop it down
to the right width after.
Cutting acrylic is
more like scoring
and breaking acrylic.
You don't slice all
the way through it,
you cut a deep enough line
that it's slightly weaker there,
and then you snap it over
the corner of something sharp.
All right, I've run several cuts
down through there,
and I mean,
I haven't even cut 1/4
of the way through,
but it's enough weaker
that I can now take the acrylic,
put it over the edge
of our bench here.
Very nice.
And it just snaps pretty clean.
So in theory,
this now fits into
the slot we just cut.
So we want just a little bit
of extra acrylic on the sides,
so we can adjust
it as necessary.
So I'm just lining up
with phone screen.
[Music]
Yeah.
Unfortunately, acrylic
over time will get scratches
and dust on it, unlike glass,
but it is a lot easier to cut.
[Music]
Yeah.
We don't really need
any height above the top
of the reflecting screen.
So let's mark right there,
and then cut both of these posts
off of that height.
[Music]
So if you have the tools for,
and if you know
how to cut glass,
you could use a glass screen.
It would last
a little bit longer,
but acrylic is
very easy to cut,
very easy to handle so...
And it's cheap.
Let's measure to put
a roof on to this.
And before we start gluing
all the pieces together,
there's one more step
we want to take.
We talked about how we
wanted to avoid vignetting.
That's when there's
something on the sides
that showing up on screen,
and I'm simulating it
by just giving myself
blinders at the moment.
If these are
on the edge of the lens,
and they're too far forward,
then you're going to see
them on the sides,
and you're not trying
to record this.
You just want it to be
there holding stuff.
So to make sure that we
don't get any vignetting,
any blocking of the visual,
we're also going to cut
out just a little bit
of a curve shape into these,
to try and minimize
any accidental encroaching
on the sides.
There you go,
and you normally will not see
that in movies,
but a really easy example,
turn on your camera phone,
and just put your hand
to the side.
You'll see it.
In the situation like this,
less is more.
Don't melt your phone.
[Music]
Let's measure for the back.
Before we attach
the back however,
we need to add something else.
We're going to have
this back attached
to the lens of the camera,
and not just through the foam,
we're going to be using
our craft foam as a collar
that fits around the lens,
because that way,
it won't just be one ring
around the lens,
but actually a bit
more of a collar.
Here's a one and a half
inch strip of our craft foam.
And now, we're just going
to measure around the lens,
and glue that into a circle
that fits right around it.
[Music]
Very nice.
Now, there's our back piece.
Here you go.
Now, we want to trace
out the same shape,
the size of the foam,
not just the lens,
but the foam itself.
That's what's going to be glued
to this piece of foam core.
The really nice part
about working with foam core
and foam is it's
usually pretty forgiving.
So even if it
isn't a perfect circle,
it's still gonna work.
[Music]
Nice.
Here we go.
[Music]
Looks good.
Perfection.
The teleprompter box
is mostly built.
There's one more thing
that we might want to do.
We can see how nicely
it fits right over that lens.
Beautiful.
And the last thing
that we want to add on is
a little bit of support,
because the box itself is
actually quite lightweight.
Once I add the phone,
it's going to get
a little bit heavier,
and it can start
to droop a little bit,
and aside from that,
you're really putting more
weight on the end of the camera,
which is going to make
your hands tired
if you're holding the camera,
so we just want to add
a little bit of support.
On this one,
what we're going to do is
we're just going to have a piece
that extends off the bottom,
and rests up against
the base of the camera.
So if it does try
and tip it all,
its leverage is pushing up
against the bottom
of the camera base.
It should center the weight
so it's all much easier.
[Music]
You can see what it looks
like through the teleprompter,
and you can see what it looks
like from the other side,
through the camera.
There's our cameraman.
Look, it's not Grant's wife.
So now we want to
challenge each other.
So the plan here is we
are both going to put something
on the teleprompter
for the other person,
and not tell them
what it's going to be.
And then see how it look.
Now, while she does that,
I want to talk a little bit
about what we are seeing
in that lens.
You may have noticed
that every letter
is slightly doubled,
its like there's a shadow
behind the letters,
and that's because
our acrylic has two sides
that are reflecting.
It's not a very
thick sheet of plastic,
but the letters are reflecting
off of one side of the acrylic,
and then they're reflecting
off of the back
of the same side of the acrylic.
So you do get
a slight ghosting effect.
If you're using a
professional-grade teleprompter,
they have a few ways
to get around this.
One is by using
a piece of glass,
and it will usually be
a little bit thinner,
and it will have a special
reflective coating applied
to it in just the right spots,
in just the right amounts
so that it reflects
the words nicely,
but you can still
see through it,
and you don't get
that doubled ghosting effect.
This however works pretty well
for a cheap version
you can throw together.
And if you have
decently large text,
it's not a big distraction.
Good when you are.
I don't know what it is
I'm about to read,
but I'm gonna give it a shot.
A long time ago,
in a galaxy far far away,
it is a period of Civil War.
Rebel spaceships striking
from a hidden base have won
their first victory against
the evil Galactic Empire.
Nice.
And there's a nice title crawl,
just scroll right up there.
Calli's turn.
Your turn.
All right.
I gotta think of something good.
Look, if you had one shot,
one opportunity to seize
everything you ever wanted,
one moment, would
you capture it,
or just let it slip?
His palms are sweaty.
Arms are heavy.
There's vomit on his sweater
already, mom's spaghetti.
He's nervous,
but on the surface,
he looks calm
and ready to drop bombs.
But he keeps on forgetting
what he wrote down.
The whole crowd goes so loud.
I think we can do this.
Really?
I give you Star Wars.
You give Eminem?
That song won an Oscar.
We went ahead and modified one
of our teleprompter builds,
and now we just have
this nice little thing
that we can drop a smartphone
into, and use the built-in
camera on that.
It's going to do the same thing.
You can film through the back,
stays in place.
You can see everything
that the camera sees.
Thanks to my friend Brigham
for sharing your experiences,
and what you learned
as you're designing
and inventing this thing.
It's really cool version.
Guys, if you aren't going
to be using this DIY version,
if it's something you think
you're going to use a lot,
every day,
or for lots and lots of videos,
it's probably worth investing
in a professional grade version
rather than the DIY.
It's got some advantages,
but this is definitely
going to work
if you're just going
to be using it occasionally.
Hey guys, that's all for today.
But you know,
we've always got more
for you to see.
If you hit that box at the top,
it will take you directly
to our last video.
You should check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you hit that bomb
in the middle,
you'll be subscribed
to our channel so you
never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.